sergey versus uh la meldita we got
marduk versus kazuya and i mean i think
sergey's definitely been making a fan of
out of a lot of people recently with his
online play
but his kazuya has been looking so sick
and he's doing it in front of two kazuya
stands
it's tight i don't even notice that
eagle in the middle of the stage right
there before what
that just blew my mind hey these
firefighters are watching the fight
rather than taking out a fire
either dude
this stage really just makes you realize
how incompetent the technical one like
world is
that is so funny
wow
what a low parry
get the wall just short canceled it nice
job
oh it didn't work out very interesting
guess the low period again
yeah
good low period trying to get a tech
trap maybe but nice
immediately after that the pressure
doesn't stop
oh no
little boy legs guess the race drive
activates the devil form what we can
harada's healthcare save them
and wall carry oh and we're going for
the ground throw mix that's a 50 50. oh
wall bounce that was so sick i step two
goes into bts to evade the electric so
smart well nice gets the big boy wall
combo man but every time dude circus
gone low parry three times in two rounds
so far
yeah that's big right he's making those
reads on those hell sweeps and oh my god
oh my god no
when is it gonna stop man he's still
partying takes the guaranteed flip over
doubles up on the low takes the frames
yeah sergey just seems to be having a
little trouble trying to get any offense
started
here it's crazy
wow
beautiful back ass electric with punish
got the wall
you're gonna break it yep
carry to the other wall no goes for all
right
very patient but he does have blue rays
driving spend it didn't get the steel
pedal doesn't matter gets the whip on
from the down forward one sergey still
staying solid
fight
loosening up i saw a glimpse of that in
the last i love it
wow the cobbles facing awareness on that
down for one double
you know how i use i i like to say like
how pete how certain characters have
easy combo routes to change it up it's
like kazuya doesn't have a combo right
it's constantly evolving oh that was so
sick
oh nice walking
dead and that's the throw mixie and he
gets the ungrounded unskill
marduk is a monster
i mean yeah when you make those right
reads too but now but it's just not even
that though right you got to give it up
for uh la modita's his defense right
those first two rounds he won straight
up off of those low parries right he and
those were low parries on hell sweeps
too so he wasn't necessarily like oh he
saw the hell sweep and he low period no
he's just slow pairing at the right time
because he knows like i need the low
perry something and i have a feeling sir
he's going to go for a low here and
every time he's got a low period he's
capitalized on it you know so
big big win there you know we do know i
do know sergey has other characters i
don't think he'll go to him but you know
there was afina pic before that i know
that he's he's known for so i don't see
it happening though but his because we
look so nice right now it's just one of
those things where
uh la modita is just playing so well
right now you know actually not that i
recall i think when they played it i
think they played that evil and he used
athena
to beat him
so
that could actually come into play here
yeah you're right i mean he does plays
athena too really strong as the theme of
secondary but everybody loves the
kazooie and then how could you not
the the sexy weiboos the electrics yeah
how could you not love that
it's hard it's hard to not like kazuya
he's too sick
yeah and also too like since llama
detail was getting so many of the low
ferries on point uh sergey went for the
four four three and the one time that he
got it unfortunately oh yeah
yeah he had two combos that seemed like
they both could have hit and they both
just lived and it could just be because
marduk is one of those characters where
he's big but he's also small for some
reason
return marduk's old hurt box just saying
violet systems gotta love it my favorite
ost and tekken 7 let's go
i bet you during the during this off
time you see all those monitors on the
side i bet you they show twitch streams
creating combat 4.0 while watching
twitch streams
wow
called him out on that too later threw
that out from downtown and look at the
combo damage there
he got warmed up for the big boy combos
though with the [ __ ] bomber earlier
yeah the way that he wasn't tech rolling
there sergey had his scouted he's like
oh this guy wants to go for the load he
wants to go for the low for the tackle
pressure afterwards yep
oh [ __ ] that down back to doing so much
work gets guaranteed doesn't want to
carry once again
oh he tried
not to punish him he wanted though but
they're interested in the wall setting
one bts cancel pressure doesn't matter
who gets the race right double form
activated are we gonna see the mid
electric
i mean sergey loves this devil
double form always three just seems like
uh it never works out yeah i know i know
i want to see a workout
all right two two points moving to the
four four three getting him duck
whoa
i'm telling you man these kazoo combos
are just all freestyles
nothing nothing is like a set cobble
right nice
turkey bringing it all the way back look
at that
this thing got the electrics to it
gets the high front
a lot more four four threes now a lot
more four four threes lava detail
challenging with the down back twos
oh
not scared to throw out that wall
signing one he loves that move
such a great check marduk's fastest boss
guitar
it's not even gonna matter
three rounds sergey take it over la
meldita to tie it up 1-1 man it looked
good too man that was very very clean
just solid kazuya play right getting the
mix-ups in getting the launchers in and
even you know lava detail he did get
that one round a lot of candidates but i
mean that's martic too right marti ken
has that ability so it's a close ass set
it was very very close
and then that said too it was just like
he remembered from the data from the
first game he's like you're low paying
everything i'm gonna four four three
everything good like deal with that
a lot more four four threes a lot more
mids but then that's what opens up the
hell sweeps again right so that's why
you know you might see a hell sweep now
and then because like you know now
you're worried about the forward four
three so if i'm the tournament player
here in this scenario i'm scared you
know the first round he had the low
defense second round the mid defense
wasn't there and now for me the data's
reset it's just like what do i do now go
back to the lows go back to the mids
hard you know hard to call out you throw
them
no wait that doesn't work either because
if they start blocking low you get
launched uh you don't do anything you
block
that's all
yeah
we're scared out here
that throws a huge wrench in the gear
right there
oh bad but yeah good adjustment by
sergey there in game number two i mean
llamadita did get that one round but for
the most part it seemed very
controllable and we got
yeah and honestly i was not anticipating
that i was like i'm fairly confident
he's the stick with marduk but the
miguel does come out
right and the marduk was doing so well
very interesting choice
statue thing in the background that is
really crazy that you can't ever see
yeah you'll never see it right
well you only notice it during during
rage arts and stuff when someone gets
thrown in time yeah
oh wow
sidewall turns into a forward wall wide
uh hell sleeps are back baby
yeah man this is not looking good for
maldita here
oh try the whiff punish or block
punishment while standing one two don't
know if that's punishable yeah it's only
11 actually really for example for
looking generic low usually those are
the ones that are like minus 20.
[Music]
dude sergey is speeding going faster now
he's keeping it up that was sick
he's turning it up down short of
blockable car
yo
that long couples too dude he's loose
big here unfortunately he doesn't have
tackle so he's got to do it all with
miguel
oh miguel's got baby arms i know the one
two didn't even reach the wall standing
two
[Music]
[Music]
every time miguel says yeah he's getting
launched get ready to fly that's me
but good stuff to serve you there a lot
more detail than the gelatin it ends up
working out but great try man great run
once again yeah i mean i